Salut à tous c'est les Pêcheurs de Trésors
On se retrouve pour une partie de pêche à l'aimant
Et là on a déjà quelque chose
Et j'ai déjà ma tenue de plongée, vous verrez pourquoi plus tard
ça vient
Tu as entendu le bruit ?
Un bruit de tôle
Ouais ça bulle bien
tu penses à un morceau de voiture ?
Ouais
Je suis dessus
ça se soulève un peu
Il est coincé dans le bord ou pas vraiment ?
Non c'est bon
Oh un cadre de moto
Ce n'est pas étonnant
C'est un cadre qui appartient à une moto ça
C'est quand même bon signe
Ouais
Bon signe parce que je n'ai lancé l'aimant que deux fois
je glisse
Tu l'as ?
il n'est pas très vieux en plus
et il est entier
Ouais super
C'est un sacré morceau, impressionnant
Belle bête
Il ne paraissait pas lourd au début
Heureusement il n'était pas trop pris dans la vase
pas trop
La partie de pêche à l'aimant commence bien
Très bien
Allez super
Tu vois qu'il fallait jeter l'aimant ici
Regardez ce réglage de la nouvelle go pro
Pendant que je me déshabille
le grand angle est incroyable
Dîtes moi en commentaires si ça vous donne le mal de mer ou pas
Mais ouais c'est étonnant
Dîtes nous aussi si vous savez quel type de moto ça peut-être, elle devait être jolie
Oui ils doivent savoir en commentaires
Il peut y avoir des coffres forts ici
J'ai l'impression d'être la voiture de Google Maps avec cet angle de vue
Bon par contre ça nous est déjà arrivé de trouver seulement un cadre à un endroit, et rien d'autre
Ils les jettent un peu de partout
Ouais c'est ça
On va voir si cela se reproduit ou non
Ah il y a un truc ici
Oh purée
Ah ouais ça va être lourd
je prends mon aimant alors
Oh purée
Celui là va nous embêter
C'est pas un rocher ?
Non non c'est aimanté
Il est juste au bord
Aide moi à tirer sur celui-là
Sur le tiens ? Ouais
On va voir un peu si ça bouge
tire sur la même ligne que moi
ça a lâché
Ouais ça bulle bien
ça c'est bon signe vous voyez
Quand il y a autant de bulles
Je le tire de nouveau
C'est peut-être un autre cadre
On serait tombés sur un spot de trafiquants de pièces de motos et scooters
Etonnant
Dans le coin, non pas étonnant
Tu penses à un scooter entier ?
Ah peut-être oui
C'est vrai qu'il avait l'air bien lourd
Qui sait...
Il ne bouge plus, on l'a coincé dans le bord
Tu vas devoir descendre l'attacher
Ah bien oui c'est un cadre
Attends tiens le comme ça
je vais essayer de l'attraper par l'avant
Il a l'air lourd
je ne sais pas si c'est un booster, c'est peut-être un T-max il est lourd
1,2,3
Non, il faut aller dans l'eau...
Ou alors on fait un lasso autour du guidon
Ouais puis on le fait basculer sur le côté
On va tirer le lasso
Viens on débloque mon aimant d'abord
Je viens d'avaler un moustique
ça se mange
Ouais mais bon il était vivant
Donc là on a remarqué qu'il y a le guidon et tout le cadre, et peut-être même une roue
Ce qui explique le poids et le fait qu'il n'arrête pas de se coincer dans la berge
Quentin va soulever le guidon pendant que je vais tirer
passe le guidon dans la boucle
je remonte et on tire à deux ? Ouais
Ah non il n'y a pas la roue
franchement elle est froide l'eau
C'est le temps que l'eau chauffe dans ta combinaison ça
Non.Si
Alors rasta qu'est-ce qu'il se passe ?
On va le sortir, t'es content ?
rasta, t'es content ?
Non ne bois pas ça on va te donner de l'eau, Non non
Allez monte
t'es punis
Monte on va t'en donner de l'eau fraîche
Attends là, assis
C'est bien
vas y essaie de tirer là
je tire les deux corde du coup ? Ouais
Je vais attacher les cordes à Rasta
Rasta file
C'est bon ça !!
c'était tout juste non ?
Ouais !
Parfait
j'étais couché pour faire contrepoids
Tu devais être limite, je pouvais pas trop pousser dans la pente
Mais au moins pas de soucis de rochers ici
Ce n'est pas un booster, c'est un gros modèle
peut-être un 125 cm3 à la limite
Ok bon déjà regardez moi ça
J'espère que vous êtes fiers de nous
Là c'est du bon nettoyage de cours d'eau les gars
Dîtes nous en commentaire ce que cela peut-être
C'est quoi comme réservoir ça ? de l'huile ?
Tiens Rasta
C'est une moule qu'il y a là dedans !
Regardez
Une moule invasive ?
Ouais
C'est presque un record de taille
On regarde s'il y a une perle ?
Alors ça ce sont des moules chinoises, une espèce invasive
On nous a donc invités à ne pas les relâcher si on en trouve
J'ai envie de regarde s'il y a une perle
Alors on va faire ça
On fait ça
Comment casser une moule avec un scooter ?
tu sais qu'après on va devoir l'emmener ?
jette là sinon Rasta va la manger, regarde le
Il se prépare déjà ce coquin
Beurk
C'est dégueulasse
ça a giclé
T'en a reçus
Si on trouve une grosse perle, ça peut-être lap lus belle pêche à l'aimant de l'histoire
La quantité de chaire par contre !
Je ne sais pas si elles sont comestibles
Ouah
je ne veux pas le savoir aujourd'hui de toute façon
Jette là à l'eau ça va nourrir les poissons
Bon il n'y a pas de perle
effectivement la quantité de chaire est impressionnante
Tu vas voir un silure énorme arriver
Ok
C'est quand même bien sympa
ça commence fort aujourd'hui
Je pense qu'on va devoir consulter un kinésithérapeute après la session
Mais ça vaut le coup
Ok
Rhaa purée
Bon je vais chercher mon aimant
ça va être trop long sinon
bah ouais
C'est bon je l'ai trouvé
Allez bouge !
Il est là !
Allez
Bonjour
C'est quoi ?
Un gros poisson en fer
C'est vrai ?
on ne sait pas encore ce que c'est, en fait on a des aimants puissants
Ah c'est pour faire quoi ?
Pour nettoyer
Ah bien
Et des fois faire des découvertes insolites, là on ne sait pas encore ce que c'est
Ahhh génial
Voilà, et là c'est bien lourd
Nous nous sommes curieuses
Là c'est plus gros qu'un vélo
Ah bon !
C'est un morceau de voiture
Ouais ouais
Un bout de voiture ?
Oui ils l'ont découpée
Vous voyez on a déjà sorti ce morceau de scooter là bas
Et là vous avez la voiture découpée, donc c'est du trafic de pièces détachées
Oh punaise
Après je vais aller dans l'eau et soulever là
Je vais essayer de ne pas écraser ça
garde la casquette toi
ça va le faire là
C'(est bien attaché ? Faut pas que ça te tombe dessus
tu veux que je tire avec toi ?
Oui je veux bien
ne te fais pas mal
Ok !!
Ensuite je pense que
1,2,3
Allez maman !
Nikel !
op c'est bon
merci beaucoup
on a eu de la chance il n'était pas trop lourd
C'est vrai qu'à 3 ça a bien aidé !
Je suis un cheval qui vient du 93 moi !
ET oui !
il y a de belles découvertes à faire aussi dans le 93
A Bondy
Ah c'est vrai ?
on a déjà pêché à Bondy oui !
Sous le pont de Bondy on était allé chercher le téléphone de Kim Kardashian
Mais non ?
Oui parce que quand elle s'est fait cambrioler
Le braqueur a dit qu'il avait jeté son téléphone sous le pont
Un deux trois
parfait
merci encore
Vous avez un petit camion ?
Oui on a un petit utilitaire
C'est bien ça
et ça tu le ramènes ou ?
chez un ferrailleur
Ah d'accord
regardez ou il est allé me tirer son aimant
c'était bien sympa, seulement 3 objets mais 3 gros objets
Bon spot
T'en penses quoi Rasta ?
Il était content ici
ouais il était bien, pas de route à proximité
ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on se retrouve tout de suite à Béziers
Pour une seconde partie de la vidéo
Il est tout petit
Regarde le il brille au soleil
Au moins on rentabilise l'utilitaire
Ouais
Faut voir ce que l'on met d'abord
Le plus chiant ça va être lui
Allez faut mettre ça dedans
ça devrait le faire, mais de peu je pense
l'arrière de la BMW était plus large, ça va le faire
Ouais mais là c'est la longueur
Dans ce sens
ça rentre tout juste
Là quand on va fermer....
Il y a de la marge
Oui c'est sûr
On met l'autre cadre dessus, ça va le faire tenir
Belle session, maintenant on va à Beziers
On est serrés mais ça va aller
Attends j'enlève l'aimant
Ah
Vous allez en faire quoi de ça ?
Celui là je ne sais pas
Comme il est volé...
Il est volé ?
Oui je pense regarde
T'as même l'attestation d'assurance, tu peux partir avec
il y a encore l'antivol là
Ah ben voilà
Regarde s'il y a encore de l'essence
Oui il y a encore de l'essence
ouais c'est de l'essence
Je pense qu'il était déjà bien pourris avant de finir à l'eau
Ils ont dû rouler un moment avec
En faisant n'importe quoi
Cette assurance termine le 15/10/21
Et il y a le nom de la personne sur le contrat
Alors Nini ?
Qui va dormir en premier ? Nini ou Rasta ?
rasta ?
On l'a sorti une fois, puis on s'est éloigné et il a été rejeté à l'eau directement
On va le faire enlever
On a le nom de la personne, c'est Philippe non ? Rodeo ?
Euh, je sais pas je l'ai pris en photo
Ah ben tu vois t'as bien fait
Volé depuis le 14 Octobre ? Ah ce n'est pas si vieux
Ben voilà la bonne action du jour, malgré la journée nulle !
Voilà
Ahaha
C'est bien pour le propriétaire
Aie mon doigt
ça va ?
il y a tout le poids derrière non ?
Quelle idée de faire ça avec des sandales aussi ?
pêcher des scooters en claquettes
AH original
T'as toujours des problèmes avec tes chaussures toi non ?
Ahah non non
hein Scotty
Ah oui exact
Durant la dernière opération de Rescue Ocean j'ai perdu mes chaussures
J'ai eu les aveux de la dame qui les a jetées d'ailleurs, je sais qui s'est
Moi aussi mais je les attends toujours
Alors Scotty ça fait quoi de faire recycler ses chaussures ?
Je ne sais pas mais j'y tenais tellement à ces chaussures
Celui qui retrouve mes chaussures dans la benne peut me demander ce qu'il veut
Scotty avait déposé ses chaussures contre un rocher avant d'aller plonger
Elles avaient été considérées comme un déchet et jetées à la benne par des ramasseurs
Et allez le vélo d'enfant !
Le voilà le vélo
est-ce qu'on ne se ferait pas un petit tour ?
Allez go